Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, soll ich dich nicht mal für einen Integrationsbambi vorschlagen?
Ich ficke dich, du Schwuchtel.
Auf dem Weg zu höheren Weinen kommen wir auch an der dreiundneunzigsten Sendung von Lokbuchnetz Politik nicht vorbei. Wir begrüßen euch äh sind wir unregelmäßig gewesen, ja, ne? Bisschen ist äh ist,
was äh weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, aber zeitliche Planungssicherheit ist gerade nicht so gegeben.
Angegriffen.
Wir schlagen uns irgendwie durch und ähm,
Ja, dann treffen wir wieder aufeinander und stellen fest, die Erde hat sich schon wieder ein wenig gedreht und Dinge äh Dinge passieren,
Sonst noch irgendwas? Wichtiges gewesen, worauf wir hier am Eingang hinweisen sollen. Wir könnten mal kurz erwähnen, was wir alles nicht erwähnt haben.
Ja, wir haben den äh Safer Internet, den ich erwähnt, ne.
Am gleichen Tag.
Sehr effizient, dass man jetzt zur Zeit die kompletten Widerstände einfach so.
Ich hätte ja gedacht, da gibt's dann mal irgendwie mal ein ein D-Dos, der sich gewaschen hat oder so.
Von wem? Von Google auf äh Scoverment?
Google hat auf jeden Fall ein bisschen Feuerkraft, wenn's um Dedos geht.
Das wäre mal ein Bot, oder? Also, ich meine, wenn so Amazon, Google.
Einfach mal so.
Microsoft und Apple, alle Server mal so richtig so, heute wird zurückgepinkt,
Das könnte schon ordentlich Feuer geben so. Also ich glaube nicht, dass Wildhouse dot gof das große überleben würde, die Frage ist, wer von Google da mal sonders dann im Anschluss überlebt. Ja.
Wenn die mal dir drossen würden, das wäre schon, also das ist ja dann, das ist ja noch nicht mal mehr D. Das ist einfach nur.
Ja, irgendwas habe ich gedacht. Ich habe gedacht, es kommt irgendein, also ja, na ja, ja, doch Carmen, es war irgendwie Verdunkelung, ne?
Ich finde, da haben sich nicht genug äh.
Ja, das müssen.
Gesenkt.
Müssen das ist immer so eine schwierige Erfahrung, wenn man dann mal eine Aktion bringt, die ähm,
gut gezündet hat, dass dann äh dass es dann sehr viele gibt, die dann das für eine sehr gute Idee halten, dass einfach bei jeder Gelegenheit wieder zu tun. Äh das ist auch bei bei anderen Aktionen irgendwie mir.
Auch meiner Meinung nach nicht unbedingt was dagegen, dieses Mittel zu nehmen. Das Problem ist nur und das zeigt sich, glaube ich, bei diesen die Internet-Strikes Back,
Day genauso wie generell in dieser ganzen Geheimdienst äh Überwachungsdiskussion, dass wenn die Ziele einfach nicht,
klar sind, nicht spezifisch genug sind, wenn's nicht äh eindeutig genug formuliert ist, was ähm,
man jetzt eigentlich konkret möchte,
dass dann einfach die Mobilisierung drunter leidet. Ja, also zum Vergleich, diese SUPA Sache,
Ja? Da ging es ganz konkret um die Rücknahme eines ganz konkreten Gesetzes vorschlages.
Der Erfolg dieser Aktion ließ sich dem daran,
messen, dass das Ganze jetzt sofort zu geschehen hat von einer Sache, die zwei, drei Wochen vorher das erste Mal so wirklich konkret,
auf dem Radar. Hier reden wir über irgendwas, wo, naja, es gibt so irgendwie so Überwachung.
Und das finden wir auch irgendwie scheiße und jeder sieht das aber auch nochmal ein ein Stück weit anders und das läuft schon irgendwie seit zehn, zwanzig Jahren und es wird irgendwie immer schlimmer,
Und es ist aber alles so schwer greifbar und so schwer auch mit Forderungen zu belegen. Also klar, man kann sagen, ja, lasst das mal sein. Ja, was denn genau? Ja, dass wir mit dem Überwachen, ja, aber,
So und die Diskussion ist einfach sehr schwierig und deswegen ist auch die Mobilisierung so schwierig. Deswegen bin ich auch nicht so ein Freund von diesen,
Hatten wir, glaube ich, auch schon, ne, dieses rituelle äh Jahresdemonstrieren.
Ja, so wir haben uns ja letztes Jahr schon gesehen, wie es demonstrieren wir wieder. Wir sind immer noch dagegen,
Und das ist nach wie vor immer alles sehr äh diffus und klar, dient ein Stück weit zur Eigenmobilisierung, aber es ist halt einfach nicht so konkret. Und eine gute,
ein guter politischer Kampf, glaube ich,
Muss auch in gewisser Hinsicht so mit Guerilla-Methoden äh und und und Ninja-Techniken auftauchen. Da muss einfach so aus dem Nichts sich so eine Zehnergruppe äh vom Dach abseilen,
und auf einmal so da sein und schwupps wieder weg.
Ja und vor allem vor allem nicht
nicht mit also vorher angekündigt und da wird das große Ding passieren und äh trag dich in unseren Newsletter ein und dann dachte ich ja immer noch okay, irgendwas werden sie ja noch in petto haben. Und dann war eben ihre einzige Sache so, ja baue diesen Code in deine Webseite ein dann äh.
Ja, das ist so Armshare-Aktivison, das ist halt, das ist halt schwierig und das das ist einfach nicht das ist nicht ungewöhnlich genug. So, meine,
Schwierig so mit den Vergleichen, aber so Greenpeace hat sich ja auch deshalb einen Ruf gemacht, weil sie immer so unvorhersagbar irgendwo auf einmal auftauchten und dann eben in sehr unkonventioneller Art und Weise. Und in gewisser Hinsicht sind es auch bei so,
Guten Hacks, die tauchen halt genauso auf. Ne, also wenn irgendwas gehackt wurde, das ist so aus dem Nichts da und auf einmal ist es irgendwie so äh brilliant auf Seite eins,
Und dann verschwinden die Ninjas auch gleich wieder.
Hat jetzt nicht geklappt.
Nee, muss man sich, glaube ich, auch grundsätzlich ein bisschen was anderes.
Ne, also ich ich bleibe auch echt dabei. Ich meine, wenn genau, muss grundsätzlich was anderes einfallen lassen, wenn's schon mal geklappt hat, kannst du's beim nächsten Mal vergessen. Da kann man, das sieht man bei so einer Freiheit statt Angstdemo, die da irgendwie ritualisiert wird,
und ähm das sieht man bei,
bei sowas eben, dass man sagt, Mensch, mit bei Sopapiper und so war das doch toll. Da können wir doch das Gleiche einfach nochmal machen. Ja, also die Aktionsform muss sich einfach auch immer wieder ändern. Das sind eben auch die Naturgesetze dieser,
Aufmerksamkeitsnummer, die man da irgendwie mit solchen Aktionen eben mitspielen muss.
Ja und vor allem ist halt das das politische System äh hat sich dann in der Regel auch nach dem nach der ersten Aktion dann auch schon entsprechend angepasst. So, das nächste Mal.
Genau, das ist genau das meine ich. Also es klappt die Aktion klappt nur einmal, egal was du machst. Also das das äh lahmt ab,
sieht man auch bei bei diesen selbst äh äh bei diesen Filmen Sachen, die kriegen zwar immer noch äh ähm ihre Artikel und ihre Bilder, weil ne, Brüste,
also muss, ist klar, aber ähm inhaltliche Auseinandersetzungen sind hier auch schon lange nicht mehr in der Lage, ähm heraufzubeschwören.
Auch zu zu viel,
zu oft, zu beliebig. Ja, weil wenn jetzt hier irgendwie jede Bobby Puppenausstellung irgendwie schon so ihren eigenen Film äh Protest bekommt, dann ist halt so mit dem generellen Revolutionswiderstand äh ist nicht so weit her.
Und dann gibt's ja auch noch andere, die äh bei anderen Anlässen.
Es kommt immer wieder vor.
Ja.
Aber äh hier ist ja ein Audio-Podcast, wir ziehen hier nicht blank, ne? Also.
Wir sind schon blank. Wir werden ja nicht.
Keiner sieht's.
Bei uns nach der wir machen ja keine Fototermine. Ähm aber Safer Internet Day wollte ich ja eigentlich noch sagen. Safer Internet Day war ja in Deutschland,
die haben da war ich überrascht. Normalerweise also ich hab gekriegt zum Internetday dann doch immer irgendwie irgendeine Anfrage dann mal in irgendein Jugend,
Parlament dann da irgendwie die den den Bürgerrechtsschützer spielen, weil sie über Internetzensur äh debattieren sollen zur allgemeinen politischen Bildung der Heranwachsenden,
oder äh Presseanfragen. Und ich glaube am Safer Internet Day hatte ich ein paar Anfragen zu E-Mail-Sicherheit. Habe ich dann mal äh,
Beantwortet, was ja, was ich ganz schön finde, dass sie diesen, also dieses Safer Internet Day, das das ist ja das haben doch irgendwelche,
Kinderschutzgruppen mal außer Versenkung gehoben. Da ging's auf jeden Fall nie um Security, sondern immer nur davor, wer was alles nicht sehen darf.
Und ähm das fand ich eine ganz schöne Wendung, die die Medien da von sich aus einfach diesen Tag gegeben haben, fand ich ganz nett.
Außerdem, Howas, war was?
Außerdem es war was, es war was. Wir haben ein Landwirtschaftsminister weniger.
Strike.
Man hätte, man hätte sicher, man hätte sicher gewünscht, man hätte sich ja gewünscht, dass er für seine,
für seine Handlung als Innenminister und zwar die die politisch relevanten Handlungen als Innenminister und die für politischen Entscheidungen als Innenminister schon sehr, sehr viel früher aus dem äh aus dem Gefahrenbereich entfernt worden wäre,
aber äh Innenminister Friedrich musste dann, wurde dann äh die der Rücktritt nahegelegt, den er dann auch äh,
angetreten ist, von seinem Amt als Landwirtschaftsminister. Ich hatte mich da noch gar nicht dran äh gewöhnt, dass da jetzt Landwirt.
Ich würde es mal anders äh formulieren. Für eine Verfehlung aus äh in Form seiner Tätigkeit als Innenminister musste er aus der Regierung äh aus dem Kabinett sich zurückziehen. So.
Weil er sich dem Verdacht der Strafvereitelung.
Ja, beziehungsweise überhaupt das Geheimnisverrat gewesen. Ja. Das ganze Programm.
Straffvereitlungen. Das ganze Programm. So, was macht, wie jetzt müssen wir äh ich habe mir da mal die Zeitleiste grob äh äh notiert. Im Mai zweitausendelf gab es eine Razzia bei einem kanadischen Anbieter von,
Filmen und Bildern, so wie ich das verstanden habe, wo auch unter Umständen Material bei war, dass,
nach momentaner Gesetzgebung, so wie es aussieht, nicht strafrechtlich relevant, jedoch ziemlich,
unanständig ist, nämlich irgendwelche,
kleinen Kinder, die jetzt anscheinend nicht oder Jugendliche, die da nicht ganz nackt sind und auch nicht in aktiven Handlungen ähm.
Doch die vielleicht sogar auch ganz nackt sind, aber die nicht äh geschlechtsspezifisch posieren. Ah ja, genau. Was auch immer.
Ah ja, genau. Also etwas, was äh so was,
nicht akzeptiert wird und der Handel damit auch, denke ich, zu Recht. Ähm,
in einem sehr äh komischen Lichte steht. Und ähm,
Dann wurde da gab's also eine Razzia bei einem Anbieter solcher Bilder in Kanada. Die haben das also ganz legal gemacht und haben mit diesen Bildern Handel betrieben. Was ja
wie mir der kurze Hinweis gestattet sei. Tatsächliche Anbieter von Kinderpornografie nicht tun, ne? Das war ja immer, dass es möchte ich nur nochmal kurz ähm
erwähnen, ähm dass tatsächliche Kinderpornografie da da sich, die ja sowieso in einem illegalen ähm,
Bereich befindet, gibt's da natürlich auch sehr viel ähm,
Raubkopiererei und Bildertauscherei, das sind also eher und das sind ja auch dann die wirklichen Meldungen, die man in den Medien liest oder hört, dass da Tauschringe äh hochgenommen werden, also äh Personen,
die ohne kommerzielles Interesse,
ähm Bilder miteinander tauschen, weil der Markt auch sehr klein ist und das äh oder die das Angebot sehr gering ist im Vergleich zu normaler Pornografie. Ähm gibt's da jetzt nicht,
tatsächlich große Anbieter für, die diesen Prozess irgendwie großartig industrialisiert hätten.
Aber die Netzursel hat doch gesagt, das wäre ein Milliardengeschäft.
Dass es ein Milliardengeschäft ähm damit meinte sie aber vermutlich eher die äh DNS äh Sperrsoftware, die sie dann äh ausrollen wollte dagegen
ähm also es wird in der Regel nicht über das oder wir sind keine Fälle bekannt, dass so etwas über das normale äh Web
angeboten wird. Ähm es mag sein, dass es da irgendwelche Zutrittsbeschränkten Foren gibt oder so, aber es gibt eigentlich keinen öffentlichen Handel
mit diesem Material, was überall auf der Welt, ich glaube, in jedem einzelnen Land der Welt illegal ist, ne. Aber das nochmal so als kurze Klarstellung zu dem zu dem.
Aber mit unterschiedlichen Nuancierungen, was jetzt genau äh verboten ist und da gibt's ja eigentlich auch genau diese Rechtslücke und äh die meiner Erkenntnis nach orientiert sich halt unter anderem an diesem Begriff, den ich vorhin schon nannte, diese Geschlechts,
spezifische Positionierung,
wo das auch immer äh anfängt und aufhört, also wenn da nicht explizit so pornografisch gepostet wird, dann äh ja, ne, ich meine.
Macht ja von, macht ja von,
ja erstmal Sinn. Du willst ja nicht, dass jeder jede Mutter, die ein äh Kind äh in die ein Foto von ihrem Kind beim Spielen am Strand, bei Rossmann irgendwie drucken lässt, äh erstmal ein paar Fragen beantworten muss. Also erst von der ähm,
von der, von dem Anspruch des Gesetzgebers her macht das erstmal Sinn,
Ich weiß jetzt, ich erlaube mir da jetzt erstmal kein Urteil, was den den weiteren, was jetzt diesen Spezifischen Fall angeht. Das müssen Leute sehen und entscheiden, die diese Bilder dann tatsächlich auch gesehen haben.
Ja, wir wissen ja nicht genau, was da jetzt wirklich konkret erworben wurde, aber es wurde wohl das ein oder andere erworben, unter anderem auch von Deutschen Staatsbürgern.
Genau, achttausend Deutschen,
Achttausend Kunden in Deutschland hatte dieser kanadische Anbieter wieder in zweitausendzwölf ähm bekannt gegeben wurde. Und am fünften November zweitausenddreizehn erfuhr dann die Staatsanwaltschaft Hannover äh,
auch setze sich damit auseinander, denn ähm,
Kanada gab irgendwie die Ermittlungsergebnisse bekannt und irgendwann so in dieser Zeit hm haben hat Kanada, da haben die kanadischen Behörden dann wohl auch der Staatsanwaltschaft in Deutschland,
Ähm mitgeteilt, wer da so auf der Kundenliste stand. Und da fand sich dann der Name des Herrn Edati, SPD,
drauf.
Kundenliste, da bin ich mir jetzt zum Beispiel schon mal jetzt gar nicht so ganz so sicher, was das jetzt eigentlich war. Also es war wohl Kreditkartendaten, die da im Wesentlichen rübergingen. Ja und,
Die waren unter anderem Zuordnung bei. Ist es der Name natürlich in den Medien viel äh,
hin und her gereicht worden. Das Interessante ist natürlich, dass äh wie heißt man mal, Sebastian, ne? Sebastian sieht das ja ausgerechnet zwanzig dreizehn natürlich im Prinzip so eigentlich seinen politischen Höhepunkt äh hat,
zelebrieren können, zelebriert hat,
NSU-Ausschuss sich durchaus äh seine Meriten äh verdient hat, den er ja geleitet hat, richtig, ja, ne?
Leitete den Untersuchungsausschuss zum NSU, war Mitglied im Rechtsausschuss und äh Vorsitz des Innenausschusses. Innenausschuss äh war aber nur bis zweitausendneun.
Also durchaus ein äh profilierter und potentiell aufstrebender Politiker, wo man auch vielleicht sogar davon hätte ausgehen können, dass er jetzt bei der Regierungsbildung,
der großen Koalition auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise mit einem Pöstchen bedacht werden könnte vielleicht,
Zumindest dachte, dass die CDU.
Das dachte die CDU, aber äh kurz, es gab dann, also das dachte sich vor allem der Bundesinnenminister, der,
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt Hans-Peter Friedrich hieß
und dann den Thomas Oppermann und den Sigmar Gabriel darüber in Kenntnis setzte, dass es Ermittlungen gegen den Herrn Edati gebe und dadurch darauf hinwirken wollte, dass diese Personalie
nicht in äh in nichts zur Debatte steht bei der Formierung einer ähm großen Koalition.
Und am sechsten Februar hat aber zum Beispiel schon die äh Staatsanwaltschaft ach so, nee, genau.
Am achtundzwanzigsten November hatte Edaties Anwalt aber sich schon bei der Staatsanwaltschaft nach einem Verfahren erkundigt gegen,
Unklar wieso, aber er hat einfach nur gefragt
gibt's hier was. Jetzt sollte der natürlich zu dem Zeitpunkt, würde man davon ausgehen, er hatte Kenntnis, der hatte Sorge und ist ähm hat sich einen Anwalt genommen, hat den Anwalt da anfragen lassen,
Auf jeden Fall kommen wir mal langsam zum Skandal. Wir müssen jetzt alles hier, was die Leute eh schon jeden Tag jetzt im Radio äh rauf und runter werden, nochmal wiederholen. Auf jeden Fall hat Friedrich dann irgendwann davon Wind bekommen und hat äh das,
ja. Zwei Personen gesagt, die sicherlich ein sehr großes Interesse haben sollten, das dem,
auch mitzuteilen.
Hm, meinst du? Das ist irgendwie, dass ihr großes, ich glaube, dass ihr vor allem erstmal das das Interesse daran gesehen wurde, dass da nicht die falsche Entscheidung aus den Augen der CDU oder.
Das ist ja richtig, das wird die das wird ja tatsächlich, also ich würde ja fast mit dem,
Also es gab ja der Heiner Lauterbach, nee heißt nicht Heiner, wie heißt der denn, Karl Lauterbach von der SPD,
häufig bei dem bei dem Jauch zu äh zu Gast ist, Karl Lauterbach, ne, genau. Der ähm sagte, sagte ja sogar, dass das eigentlich dem dem,
dass Friedrichs sich um das Land verdient gemacht hätte,
indem er, sage ich mal, den Skandal, der äh große Koalition und dem Land erspart hat, dass ein äh tatsächlicher Spitzenspitzenpolitiker in eine solche,
in ein solches Licht gerückt wird, sondern nur einer, der es hätte werden sollen und wegen einer Vorwarnung dann nicht geworden ist,
was sagst du denn dazu, Tim?
Die haben alle eine Meise. Also ich meine, erstens, was hat das Land damit zu tun? Ich meine, klar,
Das wäre dann rausgekommen, dann wäre er nicht Minister geworden oder was auch immer, vielleicht irgendjemand für ihn so als Posten vorhergesehen hat. Vielleicht stand er auch gar nicht auf der Liste. Ich meine, wenn ich mir so das Line-up der SPD anschaue, das sind so äh,
Leute, die sich eigentlich jetzt schon seit Jahren vor den Futter trögen, äh gedrängelt haben
dass da jetzt äh ein Aufsteiger des Jahres mal so äh mir nichts, dir nichts da aus der zweiten oder dritten Reihe äh gleich in so Regierungs äh Posten oder Staatssekretärsposten kommt. Gut, kann ich nicht ausschließen, aber
unmittelbar auf der Hand und ich meine und wenn schon,
Meine Schaden ist so oder so groß, ob er nun Bundestagsabgeordneter oder potentieller, was weiß ich ist. Ähm,
Schaden vom Land, finde ich, äh wurde halt nicht abgewendet, sondern wurde eigentlich erst erzeugt. Und ich fand ja auch vor allem äh sein Interview dann im Nachgang wirklich sehr interessant, wo dann Friedrich natürlich mal wieder so komplett,
realitätsfern für meinen Geschmack,
argumentiert hat, naja, dass äh was er da macht, das wäre ja total richtig. Und wenn die Gesetze äh dagegen werden, dann müsste man die halt ändern.
Also das fand ich ja nun wirklich richtig geil, ja? Und das.
Ist halt auch völlig unzurechnungsfähig. Gewe.
Ja, aber der ist Innenminister gewesen. Ja, aber zu lange. Ja, die kurze Zeit war schon echt zu lange, aber ich meine, was ist denn das bitte für ein,
Für ein Selbstverständnis,
Dass man sagt, na ja, also meiner Meinung nach, war das richtig und sollte jetzt zufällig äh ich gegen Gesetze verstoßen haben, dann muss man die halt ändern.
Nein, das war ganz klar nicht richtig und es ist auch völlig ein völliger Skandal, dass dass jemand als Innenminister äh ermittlungs,
Ergebnisse oder von noch nicht öffentlichen Ermittlungen berichtet und zwar Personen, wo ganz klar ist, dass die mitunter großer Wahrscheinlichkeit
ähm die die betroffene Person warnen werden.
Das will ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber wo man zumindest davon ausgehen muss, dass wenn man sie erstmal so nah in dieses Milieu hineinträgt, dass sie auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise weiter liegen.
Der hätte vor allem und da da bin ich ja mein, da bin ich echt mal dran interessiert. Die einzige Person, sage ich mal, wo ich wo, also wo er auch schon wahrscheinlich seinen ähm,
seine ähm,
sage ich mal, wahrscheinlich das gegen Gesetz und Moral verstoßen hätte, aber sich auf irgendeine Form von Geheimhaltung hätte berufen können, wäre Angela Merkel gewesen, hätte zu Angela Merkel gehen können und sagen können.
Ja, das ist auch, glaube ich, rechtens.
Übrigens.
Sie ist ja die Kanzlerin.
Vorstellen, dass das sogar rechtens ist, dass er sagt, äh Frau Merkel, wissen sie, ich ich suche ihren Rat als meine Chefin
In dieser Angelegenheit, die ich hier liegen habe. Ich würde sagen, ich behandele das einfach wie alles andere auch, aber gut, dass wir mal draufgeschaut haben. So, dann hätte sie ihre Schlüsse daraus ziehen können, dann hätte
hätte sie eventuell einfach in jeglicher Koalitionsverhandlung sagen können, sie hätte, ja, das wäre also,
Hätte man an, hätte man geschickter spielen können. Aber dass irgendjemanden zu erzählen und äh zu diesem Zeitpunkt war, Sigmar Gabriel, irgendjemand,
ist eben nicht in Ordnung,
Und ähm ich meine, also so ein und jemanden, der das auch noch, der da auch noch für eine Sekunde drüber nachdenkt, dass dass das in Ordnung wäre oder dass man die Gesetze dann eben anpassen müsste, um sein Verhalten abzudecken, ist,
Okay Friedrich, er ist weg, er ist weg. Er ist über die Kinderpornografie Affäre eines anderen gestürzt. Das dürfen wir nicht vergessen. Ich meine, das ist auch echt das kriegt auch nur er hin, ja. Also weißt du.
Eines Mitglieds einer anderen Partei, muss man.
Und dann noch einer anderen Partei, ja? Und da kriegt er das sofort hin. Okay, Friedrich Weck, jetzt wird's natürlich interessant.
Aber man merkte auch, es ist zwar so richtig so, keiner vermisst dich. Ja, also es gab da keinerlei großes Bedauern.
Was war denn da los? Ich habe das äh er hat ja dann noch irgendwie, jetzt schlage ich zurück. Gab's da deinen Spiegel Online-Titel, dann äh Ex-Minister schlägt zurück, weil er sagte, findet er jetzt nicht in Ordnung. Er ging ja dann noch von der, von der Bühne mit den Worten, ähm,
Ich komme wieder, wo ich alle,
wo ich ein Terminator dachte, weißt du.
Oh
Fährt der mit dem Trecker irgendwie durch die Wand oder so,
Na ja, okay, also das ist schön.
Terminator Friedrich.
Denn aber jetzt, ne, machte sich dann irgendwie vom Acker,
meldet ihr sich ja irgendwie wegen aus Gesundheitsgründen sofort alle Ämter niedergelegt, verlor dann noch ungünstigerweise seinen Laptop, nachdem gerade die die Bundesstaatsanwaltschaft äh.
Im Zug nach Amsterdam oder so? Nach Holland.
Ja ja, genau.
Opala, hat es aber auch erst zwei Wochen später gemeldet?
Ja, merkst du ja nicht sofort.
Ach ja, dieses dieses Ding.
Dieses ähm.
Dieses Ding, was die anderen immer wollten, dass sie's mitführe, damit ich nicht so unmodern aussehe. Ja, also,
Der macht keinen besonders gutes Bild in dieser ganzen Geschichte. Ich fand's aber überhaupt bemerkenswert, wie sich so die komplette,
ähm Berichterstattung in diesem Fall in null Komma nix einfach vollkommen auf alle anderen stürzen,
Normalerweise wird ja dann die Person zerrissen, ja?
Diesem Fall werden eigentlich seit zwei Wochen im Wesentlichen alle anderen äh zerrissen. Und es ist natürlich schon so, auch wieder so ein bisschen merkwürdig, wo kommen diese Informationen letztlich her, ja. Ich meine, gut Friedrich,
Hat halt was gesagt, das war jetzt schon mal der Fehler, ob das jetzt so der einzige Durchstecher war, weiß man auch nicht.
Da wird jetzt natürlich lange rumgehauen. Es es gab natürlich also das, das, das,
Ich meine, der ist halt vorgewarnt gewesen, ne? Das ist ja, das ist ja relativ klar. Es gab ja diesen Brief von der äh Staatsanwaltschaft an den Norbert Lammert,
der wahrscheinlich immer noch der Vorsitzende des Bundestags ist oder Bundestagspräsident, Bundestags.
Bundestagspräsident ist er ja genau.
Und ähm dieser Brief war aus irgendwelchen Gründen sehr lange zu lammert unterwegs und quasi schon einen Tag nachdem die Staatsanwaltschaft diesen Brief abgeschickt hatte,
und er aber noch nicht in den Händen von Lammert war, legte Edati das Amt nieder,
Das heißt, es ist relativ naheliegend, dass der irgendwo irgendwelche Quellen hatte. Muss nicht unbedingt jetzt friedlich gewesen sein, aber irgendwas hatte der da. Ähm,
der hat jetzt spätestens dieser äh ungünstigerweise verloren gegangene Computer,
Lässt auch ganz klar erkennen, dass dass er da jetzt offensichtlich Beweismittelvernichtung betreibt. Ähm was ja der interessanter Punkt ist ja noch, dass der ähm,
dass, wie gesagt, noch im Raume steht, dass dieses Material aus Kanada im Zweifel nicht illegal ist.
Scheint ja wirklich so zu sein. Ich meine, wenn die kann wenn eine kanadische Firma damit jahrelang offenen Handel betreibt, mehr oder weniger, wenn die Staatsanwaltschaft hat das so geäußert, dass da die Strafrechtlichkeit ähm und in Frage steht.
Was jetzt natürlich dann äh uns äh politisch vor die Situation bringt, dass natürlich alle jetzt schreien, dann muss es eben unter Strafe gestellt werden. Keine Sau hat die Sache jemals gesehen.
Kein Gericht hat sich ausführlich mit der Sache jetzt beschäftigt, niemand, aber es muss ja was getan werden.
Es muss was getan werden
muss verboten werden, muss äh unter der ne, gar keine steht überhaupt nicht zur Debatte, also ich ich will da jetzt ich will mich echt nicht in die Situation bringen
irgendwie jetzt da zu dem zu halten, ne. Aber ich würde mir echt wünschen, dass es irgendwie so ein Rechtsstaat irgendwie das so rechtsstaatliche Prinzipien irgendwie noch so ein bisschen gewahrt werden. Und das war irgendwie uns darauf einigen, dass wir irgendwie Gesetze formulieren, die
äh dann eben für alle gelten. Und von mir aus, wenn wir feststellen, dass die untauglich sind, daran auch Änderungen vornehmen, aber dann noch bitte unter Kenntnis aller Umstände. Und nicht irgendwie als im, im, im kleinen Fascho, äh Kneipen äh Stammtischgespräch.
Mein Fit ist eh noch mal ganz spannend ähm so ein paar Sachen, also zum Beispiel die es gibt ja diese Unterstellung, er habe manche dieser Daten auch im Bundestag heruntergeladen,
gab's so diese Formulierungen im Raum, um um das sozusagen zu verschleiern, was da jetzt, warum jetzt ausgerechnet der Bundestag ein guter Ort sein soll, um solche Sachen zu verschleiern.
Ich habe keine.
Erschließe ich mir nur so halb, ja? Dann äh ja, dann dann wurden sein Büro, was er dann geräumt hat, wurde er dann auch,
Unmittelbar sofort an die Nachfolgerin vergeben. Die Nachrückerin,
sodass quasi so Beweismittel an der Stelle auch nicht klar sind, dann stellt sich dir auch die Frage nach Backups, ja, wie ist das überhaupt jetzt mit den Computern da im Bundestag? Da weiß ich auch, habe ich auch wirklich keinen Einblick, falls da jemand.
Etwas viel schöneres.
Ein was schöneres.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt's im Bundestag. Drei Monate.
Sprechen von was? Von Kommunikationsdaten.
Von Kommunikationsdaten, von Internetverkehr, drei Monate.
Ja
Obwohl es dann.
Herr ist ja, sagen wir mal auch der Vorratsdatenspeicherung sehr äh statt da ja auch positiv äh gegenüber. Ich weiß nicht, hast du diesen äh Kommentar gesehen, den er auf Abgeordneten Watch äh in einem Srade gehabt hat?
Zu dem Thema oder hat er sich nämlich interessanterweise äh darüber beklagt, dass jemand anderes äh unter seinem Namen bei,
Hat er Amazon gesagt oder online? Äh Pornos bestellt habe.
Ach herrje.
Ja und äh das es könne ja nicht sein, ja? So, schöne Formulierung. Ich weiß nicht.
Kann ja nicht sein, sind.
Muss man diesen Link noch gleich nochmal raussuchen auf Abgeordneten Watch ist der,
Ähm und ne, also auch da wäre ja mal eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung total äh cool,
So, ich bin ja mal gespannt, was die Vorratsdatenspeicherung dann bei ihm so äh herausfindet. Wenn sie denn jetzt überhaupt herangezogen wird, weil das finde ich ja jetzt auch äh eine interessante Neuigkeit, äh dass das im Bundestag so äh schon so präsent ist,
Man muss ja auch noch dazu wissen, innerhalb des Bundestages ist ja der Bundestagspräsident quasi auch der Polizeichef,
Also es gibt ja im Bundestag eine eigene,
polizeiliche Hoheit des Bundestages und der steht halt der Bundestagspräsident äh vor. Mittlerweile ist das natürlich jetzt alles auch beim BKA gelandet und von daher glaube ich,
vom Fall her auch entzogen, aber das sind alles so,
interessante Wirkungsbereiche, wo sich jetzt diese Affäre äh abspielt, nicht nur was jetzt die politische moralische Dimension betrifft, sondern eben auch die konkrete technische Beweismittel äh Erfassung und dann wollen wir ja mal sehen, was mit diesen Daten da so passiert.
Mehr kann man dazu erstmal nicht sagen.
Ne, es gibt halt ja, es gibt jetzt noch diese,
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben, wir haben im Prinzip alles gesagt, ja. Das ist jetzt auch müßig, netzpolitische Relevanz ist erstmal nicht gegeben,
Zunächst wird aber noch kommen, also da werden wir nochmal irgendwie Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Zensur und sonst was Debatte, das werden wir jetzt alles wieder haben. Aber es hätten wir auch ohne diese Affäre gehabt.
Nee. Gut. Dann möchten wir einmal auf einen Termin hinweisen, auf den wir schon länger hinweisen äh müssen.
Ja und jetzt möchtest du, dass ich das Datum sage, ne?
Na ja, nee, du kannst jetzt nicht erst mal rausreden, bis wir die genaue Datum gefunden haben, aber das ist, sagen wir mal, jetzt etwas, was jetzt äh ansteht.
Das ist jetzt wirklich wichtig. Wir haben da auch schon mehrfach drüber gesprochen und wir hatten ja auch den äh Thomas Lohninger hier auch schon zu dem Thema zu Gast. Es geht,
um die Maßnahmen zum europäischen Binnenmarkt der elektronischen Kommunikation und zur Verwirklichung des vernetzten Kontinents über die äh das EU-Parlament jetzt irgendwie mal,
Abstimmen möchte und wo wir eben äh.
Specialized Services drin finden und ähm weitere ziemlich konkrete Angriffe auf die Netzneutralität,
Ähm ins spezifische oder insbesondere geht's da um den ähm Paragrafen neunzehn und den äh den Artikel neunzehn und den Artikel dreiundzwanzig Absatz fünf, wo,
einerseits die Gleichbehandlung,
Also in in dem äh dreiundzwanzig fünf äh können Internetprovider nach ihrem eigenen Ermessen sperren und zwar in ihrem eigenen Interesse und in Fremdeninteresse,
Können sie also in den Netzwerkverkehr eingreifen und äh Artikel neunzehn gibt den Nutzern nur die Möglichkeit, aber nicht ein Recht auf ein äh freies Internet. Mit anderen Worten. Man sagt, okay,
insbesondere diese äh Specialist Services und Eingriffe zur,
Verbrechensbekämpfung und auch Eingriffe, die nicht der Verbrechens äh Bekämpfung dienen, sind erstmal grundsätzlich erlaubt.
Und das ist ähm,
natürlich so das kann, ist wirklich eine sehr gefährliche Entscheidung, die da getroffen würde. Ähm,
Grade im Artikel dreiundzwanzig wird zum Beispiel sich bei Rober beklagt, es wird in der Verordnung von Freiheiten der Nutzer gesprochen, obwohl man natürlich von Rechten reden muss. Ich meine, als Kunde hast du keine Freiheiten. Du, also wenn du etwas hast, dann ist es ein Recht,
oder etwas, wofür du bezahlt hast. Und das ist natürlich genau das, was man bei ähm in Frage der Netzneutralität eben genau nicht möchte, ne. Es muss einfach klar sein, dass das offene Internet so bestehen bleibt und jeder Eingriff da rein,
sehr klar verhindert wird. Da gibt's also die äh Aktaktion, Kampagne Save the Internet. Ähm die ist wirklich sehr einfach macht ähm Abgeordnete zu kontaktieren. Ich habe das nämlich heute mal gemacht.
Seei Internet dot EU.
Da kann man äh das das wählt irgendwie kostenlos ein Abgeordnete Person für dich aus und dann kannst du da anrufen, der ein Fuck schicken oder eine E-Mail.
Und ähm das ist ganz äh ganz interessant. Das kann man, da gibt's dann auch so einen vorgefertigten Text, äh das ist natürlich nur
von mittlerer äh Wirksamkeit, wenn man den vorgefertigten schickt. Man kann sich ja dann noch kurz die Zeit nehmen, da ein bisschen was dran zu ändern oder zum Beispiel den Text auch auf die Sprache zu übersetzen der Person, an die man sich da jetzt ähm,
wendet,
aber das ist jetzt wirklich mal eine eine wichtige Sache. Da können können wenn das falsch entschieden wird haben wir jahrelang,
Ärger an der Backe.
Und vor allem eine eine sehr schlechte Standing uns da da wirklich jemals wieder vernünftig rauszukommen. Wir haben in den USA ja gesehen, da gab's ja die Regulation der durch die FCC,
Ich denke, das hatten wir hier auch erzählt, dass die ähm äh dass der Internet Provider Horizon,
erfolgreich gegen geklagt hat gegen die Auflagen der Regulation, die ihm da aufgebürdet wurde, nämlich dass er äh dass er einfach mal den Nutzern in Internet geben soll und ansonsten damit nix zu tun haben soll,
Dagegen hat er sich erfolgreich gewehrt. Es wurde jetzt auch heute, glaube ich, wurde dann bekannt, wie die FCC plant, ähm die Netznetralität zu retten. Und zwar geht's werden sie nicht in Berufung gegen dieses Urteil treten,
denn dieses Urteil basierte äh primär darauf, dass ähm,
keinen, warte, wie war das? Na, na, na, na, na.
Ähm also es gab eine Lücke in der Argumentation dadurch, dass die ähm FCC eigentlich nicht für Internetanbieter,
Zuständig ist, sondern für Kommunikationsanbieter. Und es gab irgendwie, also jetzt habe ich das wahrscheinlich falsch wiedergegeben, aber ähm
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen gehörten dann die Kabelnetzanbieter nicht dazu und äh konnte sich also auf einer auf einer sehr feinen Formulierung äh begründet aus dieser ganzen Nummer äh rausklagen,
und die FCC hat sich entschieden, okay, dann äh sagen wir das Urteil ein und schreiben die Regulierung einfach direkt nochmal neu und zwar so, dass sie auch für gilt. Denn das Urteil lautete
offenbar nicht, so wie ich das jetzt verstanden habe, ähm dass die FCC Horizon grundsätzlich nichts zu sagen hat, sondern dass die FC in dieser Regulation etwas gesagt hat, was für Oriza nicht zutrifft.
So habe ich das verstanden. Also in in den USA ähm,
wird die FSC einen erneuten Anlauf unternehmen, um da die Netzneutralität zu sichern.
Ja
Sollten in der Zeit uns darauf konzentrieren hier in äh Europa äh diese Regulation, wie sie jetzt ist ähm,
maßgeblich zu beeinflussen, in die richtige Richtung oder ähm zu stoppen.
Wenn ich das hier richtig äh deute, dann sieht der Zeitplan so aus, dass die meisten Abstimmungen in den einzelnen Ausschüssen schon gelaufen ist,
einschließlich des. Ich sehe bloß jetzt gerade nicht die Ergebnisse und jetzt gibt's noch einen äh Abstimmung und Abschlussbericht im Industrieforschung und Energie,
Ausschuss. Insgesamt gibt's fünf Ausschüsse, die damit beschäftigt sind. Binnenmarkt, Verbraucherschutz, Kultur und Bildung, Rechtsausschuss und eben der bürgerliche Freiheit, Justiz und Inneres,
die ganzen hier aufgeführten Daten sind jetzt verstrichen. Bleibt nur noch der vierundzwanzigste Februar. Aber kann auf jeden Fall nicht.
Bei mir ist es der zwölfte Februar.
Der zwölfte Februar ist äh für den Liebe-Ausschluss.
Und die anderen sind, achso.
Der vierundzwanzigste ist der letzte. Soweit dieses Tabelle jetzt hier die Wahrheit spricht. Das heißt, äh die anderen Sachen sind jetzt schon gelaufen. Ja, wir hätten auch deutlich früher darauf hinweisen, äh müssen aus haben wir das?
Haben wir. Haben wir das? Ja. Wir haben da immer drauf hingewiesen, regelmäßig.
Immer. Okay, na gut, dann haben wir das einfach getan. Per Aklamation waren wir einfach gut.
Nein, haben wir wirklich, wir haben der Thomas war doch erst vor drei Wochen oder vier Wochen hier. Da ging das alles los. Da hat er also das war der entscheidende Punkt.
Sprach von der Dramatisierung auf den letzten Metern.
Wir hätten das Internet verdunkeln sollen.
Wir sind dazu da, das Internet zu erhellen. So.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung hatten wir ja gerade schon.
Kann man gar nicht oft genug haben, oder?
Kann man gar nicht oft genug haben. Denkt sich auch, Heiko Maas, ja? Er war ja für kurze Zeit ein,
Brandheißer Kandidat auf äh den Orden der äh rational agierenden äh Parlamentarier und Minister. Leider,
wird er den jetzt nicht erhalten, denn er hat im Rechtsausschuss
äh Frage und Antwort gestanden und äh sagte man, er würde sich jetzt eigentlich mental so darauf vorbereiten, dass möglicherweise die Richtlinie zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung vom Europäischen Gerichtshof für,
unzulässig erklärt wird,
So viel wissen wir, dass damit zu rechnen ist, äh weil ja der äh oh Mann, ich vergesse immer seine Position. Äh,
Staatsanwalt, der hatte einen anderen Namen in seinem Bericht, dass auch so ungefähr formuliert und in der Regel das Gericht äh seinen Formulierungen äh folgt.
Ihr geht aber davon aus, dass nicht das Instrument der Vorratsdatenspeicherung selber für uns unzulässig erklärt wird.
Eben nur dieser europäische Anlass, diese Richtlinie und man könnte ja immer noch eine einführen ohne diese Richtlinie
Weil wir sind ja Deutschland und wir können das ja auch selber und das ist verfassungsgericht hat zwar schon mal weitgehend geurteilt, dass das alles äh
nach Lulu riecht, aber äh ist ja nicht hundertprozentig ausgeschlossen hat, dass es vielleicht unter Umständen eine rechtliche Formulierung gibt, unter der eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung
dann doch noch äh reduzieren könnte. Äh lustig finde ich den Dreher insofern, als dass er jahrelang immer gesagt wurde, naja, wir müssen das ja machen, weil es gibt ja diese europäische Richtlinie.
Ja Arschlöcher, oder? Was eine.
Wir denn dafür, wenn die bösen Europäer uns das so eingebrockt haben. So und jetzt so.
Bezahlen Millionen, Millionen müssen wir hier bezahlen.
Ach die die verspricht, die verstößt gegen die äh Menschenrechte,
Da machen wir dann eine menschenrechtsfreundliche Vorratsdatenspeicherung deutscher Prägung.
Ne. Da bin ich ja auch mal gespannt.
Er ist angestrebt, präventiv zu handeln.
Ja, es ist, ich weiß immer.
Nicht auf eine neue Richtlinie zu warten.
Ich freue mich jetzt allerdings, ich meine in gewisser Hinsicht frage ich mich das jetzt auch nicht, aber ich stelle mal die Frage in den Raum, ja. Wenn es also nicht diese Richtlinie ist, die ihnen so in den Rücken drückt, dass sie sich so unglaublich äh,
beeilen müssen. Was ist es dann?
Der äh Terrorismus und Kinderpornografie.
Aber glaubst du das wirklich, dass sie das glauben?
Also glaubst du wirklich, dass dass da einen politischen Konsens,
tatsächlich der Meinung ist, dass es helfen würde, obwohl es bisher nur Studien gibt, die das Gegenteil belegen, ich meine, es ist doch absurd.
Also wenn du dir ich meine, es du hast für die für die tatsächliche, also,
ganz vorsichtig gesagt, ja, für die Effizienz der des Mittels ähm Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Hast du ja nur relativ wenige Lobbyistengruppen, die dir da äh,
denen du da vertrauen kannst. Ja, und das sind die Polizeigewerkschaften,
und äh der hier die Vertreter von äh BKA äh und und von der Polizei selber im Prinzip. Ja, also Jörg Zirke und die beiden ähm Heinis von den Polizeigewerkschaften, Rainer Wendt und von der anderen weiß ich gar nicht genau, wie der heißt,
der fällt nicht so oft, nicht ganz so oft auf.
Ja, die finden das total knorke, aber das ist halt so dieses.
Dir, die erzählen dir einfach, ja, wir können unsere Arbeit nicht mehr machen, weil
Ähm hier ist überall ist ganz schlimm, Terror und und und Kinderpornographie und die die ganzen Ermittlungsergebnisse, die wir nicht haben und so und gucken sie sich mal an, hier achtundsiebzig Mörderinnen frei rum mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung hätten wir die alle gehabt.
Ja, angeblich.
Möchten sie der äh Justizminister sein, der mit irgendwelchen kruden Argumenten uns die Möglichkeit nimmt, diese Verbrechen aufzuklären?
Ja, das ist so die äh gängige Argumentation.
Natürlich kannst du als Justizminister dann nicht davon ausgehen,
dass ausgerechnet die Bürgerrechtsaktivisten, die einfach nur alle nicht überwacht werden wollen, weil sie ja irgendwie so ein sozialromantisches, äh sozialromantische Idee von diesem Internet haben, in dem alle frei sind,
dass die dir ausgerechnet eine qualifizierte Einschätzung dazu geben, ob dieses Mittel zur ähm,
Zur Verbrechensbekämpfung taugt oder nicht.
Ja, ich, die muss man ja gar nicht befragen, aber es gibt so alle Studien, die ja, ja, aber.
Genau, deswegen befragt man die auch nicht. Ja. Das offensichtlich nicht, es geht ja um Polizeiarbeit und die Verhinderung von schweren bis schwersten Verbrechen.
Ja gut, man muss ja nur die anderen Polizei äh Polizei in anderer Länder befragen, die dieses Mittel bereits zum Einsatz hatten. Wie gut es denn funktioniert hat. Und da gibt's ja auch keinerlei Berichte, die in irgendeiner Form irgendwas.
Gabriel hat doch ein wunderbares Beispiel gebracht, wie dank der Vorratsdaten der dann äh gefangen wurde auf der Insel. Weißt du noch, auf der Insel haben die den gefangen genommen. Während der da die Kinder abgeknallt hat, noch auf der Insel haben den gefangen und.
Dabei ist er nicht mit seinem für Massenmörder üblicherweise ja immer bereitstehenden Hubschrauber weggeflogen.
Dabei hatten die noch nicht mal Vorratsdatenspeicherung. So effizient ist die Vorratsanspeichung.
Wirkt sogar schon bevor sie da ist. Ja, sicher.
Ja, sicher. Hammer.
Wird uns wieder Zynismus vorgeworfen.
Ja, es ist wirklich, es ist eine, es ist ein.
Trauma.
Ich bin ich kann aber nicht mehr viel zu sagen, ja. Ich meine, okay, solange wir noch irgendwie ein Land haben, ähm,
indem es keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt, können wir vielleicht irgendwie versuchen, uns da noch mit VPNs und Tors irgendwie einen einen halbwegs Rest an an normaler,
zwischenmenschlicher Kommunikation über dieses Netz zu erlauben. Aber es sieht einfach danach aus und wenn du hier
ich will gar nicht es ich will jetzt gar nicht erst irgendwelche Namen sagen von Leuten, die die dann auch noch meinen sich da qualifiziert zu äußern zu können. Ich meine, du hast ja,
Irgendwelche,
Vögel, die aus irgendwelchen Gründen meinen, sie werden jetzt dazu kompetent, weil sie auch einen Computer haben und die dann da irgendwelche Gutachten zu schreiben und äh irgendwie die die Vorratsdatenspeicherung mit menschlichem Amt letzter formulieren.
Kurz gesagt, Vorzahnspeicherung ist nach wie vor ein politisches äh Thema, wird von einer großen Koalition erneut auf den Topf gesetzt
obwohl der ursprünglich immer formulierte Druck äh aus Europa jetzt auf einmal äh droht wegzubröseln, das zeigt, dass einfach die Motivation dafür immer schon woanders lag
Darüber sind wir jetzt auch nicht sonderlich überrascht, sondern wir
verfolgen einfach nur mit einer mit einem gewissen Interesse und einer gewissen Verwunderung, welche politische Argumentation sich unsere politische Elite jetzt einfallen lässt, um dieses Ding voranzubringen und,
gesagt, ich finde das ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht auch sehr hilflos, was da gerade passiert. Weil, ich meine, was wollen sie denn jetzt bitte,
beschließen. Also es gibt keine europäische Richtlinie, weil die halt unter Umständen komplett nicht konform ist.
Beschließt nicht einfach so. Ganz einfach.
Ja, aber welche, aber mit mit welcher Formulierung schaffen sie es, eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu zu definieren, die dem Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts nicht widerspricht.
Das ist ja überhaupt nicht schwer. Das haben die doch Tim, du meinst doch nicht wirklich, dass du jetzt nicht schon längst in der Schublade hätten.
Ja gut, aber die welche Überlebenschance hat das bei der nächsten Klage?
Ja keine eine ziemlich große, dass äh das das Verfassungsgerichtsurteil wird ja von vielen schon einfach nur als die Anleitung dazu gesehen, wie man das Gesetz neu schreiben muss,
Klar, da gibt's klare äh Punkte drin, äh denen musst du irgendwie äh sinnvoll begegnen, dann kannst du das machen.
Da wird's dann wieder eine Klage geben, klar. Aber die wird schon mal auf einer sehr viel auf sehr viel ähm.
Dünnerem Eis stehen.
Sehr viel dünnerem Eis stehen als vorher. Denn da gab's ja schon mal ein Ute, da musst du vor allem erstmal wieder einen neuen Grund finden.
Ja, muss man. Weil man es gibt ja jetzt keine Vorlage. Es gibt jetzt in dem Sinne keinerlei äh konkreten Entwurf, den man jetzt äh auf sowas hin.
Der wird aber relativ flott aus der aus der Tasche kommen. Den haben doch schon längst irgendwelche Leute geschrieben.
Da bin ich mir ganz, ganz, ganz sicher. Du meinst doch nicht, dass irgendwie so ein so einen kleinen Gesetzesentwurf, der muss ja noch nicht mal, der ist ja noch nicht mal so lang. Den hat doch, den hat doch ruckzuck jemand formuliert.
Ja, was ist denn mit der, ich meine, die Argumentation, jetzt wo es keine europäische Richtlinie gibt, da kann man ja dann sich einfach mal eine Deutsche einfallen lassen. So, äh die,
Ablehnung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Europa kann ja genauso gut auch einfach bindende Wirkung entfalten oder nicht?
Das kommt darauf an. Also das, das wäre natürlich die das,
Das wäre zu hoffen, steht aber mit diesem wenn das Gericht sich an den äh der so, hätte so einen schönen Namen Pedo Cruise oder so, ah meine Güte, weißt du, jetzt muss ich dir diesen Namen Pedro Gruß wieder lon, Entschuldigung.
Ähm das, was er formuliert hat.
Generalanwalt.
Generalarbeit. Ich wollte ja sagen, das ist nämlich ein anderer, ist ein anderer Begriff, ja. Genau. Ähm.
Ja, okay. Ist ja kein Staat. Ja, ja, passt schon, aber hat im Wesentlichen dieselbe Aufgabe.
Das, was er formuliert hat, ähm ist ja wieder hat ja wieder den Punkt so, dass es nicht grundsätzlich aus ähm ausschließt, dass ähm grob so eine Überwachung stattfinden kann.
Er sagt ja nicht, zack, bumm, grundsätzlich illegal, alles vom Tisch, hier loslassen, sondern es geht nur um diese Richtlinie wieder
die, wie wir uns erinnern, äh bei der es darum ging, den Binnenmarkt zu vereinheitlichen. Das ist ja noch nicht mal eine eine Überwachungsrichtlinie aus aus irgendwelchen Innenausschüssen oder sowas,
Da ging's ja nur um die Vereinheitlichung damit, ne, damit die Märkte ähm,
keine äh wirtschaftlichen Unterschiede aufweisen aufgrund der der Menge an Zeit äh die sie, die sie die Nutzerdaten speichern.
Also diese diese ganze Welt ist ist.
Einfach nicht die, um die es geht. Lies dir diese Sachen durch. Das ist da wirst du wirre im Kopf,
und die werden sich jeden Tag einen neuen Scheiß-Grund einfallen lassen, um das zu machen. Und dass der, dass der dass ähm diese dieser,
Argumentationswechsel von Heiko Maas,
vom bekommen hat. Dass der größtenteils irgendwie im Block von behandelt wird, ja?
Abgeordnete der Linkspartei ähm im Innen aus, ne im Rechtsausschuss tätig, wo der äh Heiko Masters dann da auch so formuliert hat,
Da siehst du, wie das grade keine Sau interessiert. Da überhaupt noch nach einem Grund zu fragen,
Die Leute haben den Drops gelutscht, wenn du gesagt hast, Millionen Strafzahlungen von der EU, ja zack, bumm, so steht's ja glaube ich sogar noch im im äh Koalitionsvertrag,
So das ist doch egal, wenn ich jetzt aus einem anderen Grund geht, Fakt ist, äh im Koalitionsvertrag stand Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Also rollen wir die jetzt aus.
Also räumen wir die jetzt auf. Okay, also Ninja-Kostüme bereithalten unter Umständen brauchen wir die noch.
Ich kriege da echt, also die Sendung hier, wir sind noch nicht fertig, ey.
Schon so einen Hals.
Krawatte hierhin gekommen da.
Ja richtig gute Laune machen auch die Entwicklungen in der äh Türkei. Wir erinnern uns da äh wird seit ähm mehreren Monaten mittlerweile da ein,
Tja, ein, ein, ein Kampf auf der gesamtpolitischen äh Ebene äh durchgeführt, sowohl,
gegen die eigene Bevölkerung, wie wir das gesehen haben, hier mit den,
Park, Demonstration ausgehenden Protest. Ähm,
aber eben auch jetzt nach dieser Korruptionsaffäre, die in der Türkei bekannt geworden ist, wo irgendwie so ja äh Söhne von Ministern ähm und teilweise wohl auch die Minister selber
in einem sehr umfangreichen Korruptionsverdacht äh standen. Auch festgenommen worden. Woraufhin äh,
tolle Ministerpräsident äh Erdogan soweit gegangen ist, einfach mal alle von der Polizei und auch juristischen Bereich einfach zu entlassen, die ihm jetzt mal so nicht gepasst haben. Also von rechts Verdrehung kann er schon überhaupt nicht mehr die äh,
Rede sein, da herrscht eigentlich, was das betrifft. Offener Krieg jetzt äh ist natürlich auch das Internet als Problem erkannt worden,
während der Demonstration, dass da nicht, die Leute haben ja dieses Twitter benutzt zum Beispiel und sich darüber,
geäußert und auch verabredet.
Vor allem sehr viel internationale Aufmerksamkeit auch äh.
Genau. Und so eine informelle äh Internetzensur gab's in der Türkei ohnehin schon. In YouTube war da äh weiß ich nicht, ob's immer gesperrt ist oder manchmal gesperrt war.
Nicht informell, sondern die war äh äh hochformell, weil äh sie das ja mit richterlichen Beschlüssen gemacht haben. Also die äh ähm es gab, die haben's schon bisher immer relativ viel gesperrt. Ähm,
aber mit richterlichem Beschluss und dieses neue Gesetz möchte jetzt, dass die Telekommunikationsbehörde ermächtigt wird, Internetseiten auch ohne richterlichen Beschluss zu blockieren,
und Internetanbieter sollen verpflichtet werden Nutzerdaten für zwei Jahre zu speichern,
was ich so wunderschön finde und das ist also dieses Gesetz wurde übrigens vom türkischen Präsidenten gebilligt und damit ist es im Zweifelsfall jetzt auch durch, ja?
Wenn ich das äh wenn ich den Gesetzgebungsprozess da richtig ähm interpretiere.
Ähm interpretieren. Denke auch.
Das heißt, sie haben jetzt diese und dann ist es,
diesen Satz, der sich einfach mal so vor direkt hier mein Gott, die Regierung erklärte,
die erleichterte Sperrung von Internetseiten solle dem Schutz der Jugend vor schädlichen Einflüssen aus dem Internet dienen und sie vor Drogen und Pornografie bewahren. Kritik aus dem In- und Ausland wies sie zurück.
Das heißt,
Das was da jetzt irgendwie hier in Deutschland groß äh ne, oh man, die Armen, der Armen türkischen Bevölkerung wird jetzt das Internet zensiert, diese
Unrechtsregime von von Präsident Erdogan fürchterlich, was der den Menschen da antut, ne? Und alles, weil er einfach nur behauptet, die die Jugend vor schädlichen Einflüssen zu schützen. Aus keinem anderen Grund werden in Deutschland solche Sperren äh,
diskutiert. Das ist, kannst du eins zu eins übersetzen. Der hält wahrscheinlich die gleichen Reden, wie die Politiker hier halten.
Ja, mit anderer Farbe. Ja, das ist.
Wobei ich sagen muss, die Gewalt, äh die die Demonstranten in der Türkei widerfährt, ist noch ein noch eine sehr viel schlimmere als äh in Deutschland. Allerdings noch nicht so schlimm, wie die in der Ukraine,
ich glaube es hat ja sogar die türkische Regierung jetzt die Ukraine getadelt, ne? Wirklich? Ukraine, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ja.
Gott, was hat einem zu gedenken geben,
Ja, was kommt da als nächstes? Kim Jong-il? Und? Die heißen? Un.
Ich muss gerade so lachen. Also vielleicht mal Bezug nehmend auf unser Eingangsgespräch. Ich habe ja ähm,
in einem Tweet, den Bushido als Integrationsbambi-Schwuchtel bezeichnet,
weil ich äh eine Liste aller seiner Beleidigung von dem neuen Album gefunden habe, die ich die mich heute hier auch in dieser Sendung maßgeblich beeinflusst hat. Man merkt,
Krawall gebürstet. Ich habe das äh ich habe die die alle Beleidigungen von äh Bushidos neuem Album habe ich in meinem Wortschatz. Und ähm.
Jetzt äh hat.
Bestimmt auch an den Internetpranger gestellt.
Jetzt kommen die Bushido-Fans.
Da hauen auf dich ein, oder was?
Du auch eine große Klappe hast, wenn der vor dir steht, Kleiner? Internet Gangster?
Ja, Bushido. Komm her.
Komm her. Ich sage dir, ich ich mache dir, ich ich sage dir, weißt du. Ist lang.
Echt genau, ja. Bushido kommt her und haut mir auf die Fresse, weil ich ihn als Schwuchtel bezeichnet habe. Schwuchtel! Okay.
Lassen wir das. Das führt nur als äh totale Elend, ja. Gut.
Totale Elend, ja. Ich wurde gewarnt, mich nicht auf dieses Niveau zu begehen.
Ja. Wir müssen uns auch über Einschaltquoten Gedanken machen, ja.
Bushido als Hörer.
Nein, die Anschaltquote, die die haben. Nein, nein. Äh ich versuche dich mal zu retten und äh wechsel mal das Thema,
Ähm wobei ich zugeben muss, dass ich bei diesem Thema überhaupt nie aufgepasst habe, Schengen
Security äh äh worum geht's da? Ach so, ja hier wollen die äh die Deutschen und die Franzosen wollen sich jetzt mal wieder ein bisschen lieb haben. Und da passt ja eine Geheimdienstzusammenarbeit äh sicherlich ganz gut, damit ja die europäische Achse gestärkt wird.
Da verließen sie ihn aber auch schon so ein bisschen. Was hast du da sonst noch.
Ja ähm es es also,
Merkel, Merkels Kabinett war in Paris, hat sich dann äh unterhalten und jetzt wollen sie die Geheimdienstzusammenarbeit stärken und sie wollen die,
äh Spionageabwehr stärken und deutsche Geheimdienste sollen auch Verbündete beobachten. Also das, was die Amerikaner machen, machen wir auch,
und gegen die Amerikaner wollen wir uns aber mit Spionageabwehr wehren. Dann geht noch einer von der CDU hin,
Das fand ich auch sehr, sehr toll,
Thomas Jarzombek.
Wurde ja auch schon öfter mal hier behandelt. Eigentlich einer der kompetenteren äh aus der aus der CDU, Mitglied im Verein C Netz und das C-Netz hat jetzt auch eine tolle Idee und sagt, wir wollen doch bitteschön für die Verschlüsselung,
Deutsche Forschung, deutsche Algorithmen setzen.
Deutscher Algorithmen für deutsche Datenautobahnen. Ja, was schwebt ihnen da so vor? Welcher Algorithmus?
Keine Ahnung
Wahrscheinlich soll sie sich neu einen ausdenken. Also das ist halt also Verschlüsselung ist äh unabhängig von äh dem
von dem äh von der Nationalität äh jenes Teams, dass sie äh entwickelt hat, das äh muss man, glaube ich, sagen. Ja, also wer äh eine vernünftige Verschlüsselung,
hält, was sie verspricht. Da äh ist es unabhängig davon,
wer an der Entwicklung beteiligt war, ja? Ähm darüber hinaus, wenn man jetzt wirklich von deutscher Verschlüsselung sprechen würde, fällt mir da nur die Chiffre ein?
Das war, glaube ich, oder Chiasamus spricht man das dann, glaube ich, auch,
aus und das ist, glaube ich, eine der wenigen ähm Verschlüsselungs,
Krypto Dingern die sag mal als Deutsch bezeichnet werden könnte und die seit Jahren kaputt ist ne?
Oder war das so, ist sie auch wirklich deutsch, also ist gar nicht.
Ja Kias muss in der in der Version eins Komma sieben ist für die Verschlüsselung von Verschlusssachen der Geheimheit des Geheimates VS nur für den Dienstgebrauch zugelassen. Und da gab's dann einen schönen Vortrag auf dem ähm,
dreißig äh C3 von Felix Schuster. Äh wenn ich mich nicht täusche,
der den ähm Reverse-Engineer hat, diese diese Schiffe. Also das ist totaler Unsinn, ne? Das ist totaler Unsinn,
Zu sagen, wir müssen auf Deutsche, auf deutsche Algorithmen äh setzen. Das ist völlig egal, wer die formuliert hat. Man, wir müssen sie nur selber prüfen.
Ich würde, ich würde dem sogar widersprechen und sagen, wir müssen auf internationale äh Algorithmen äh setzen, die wirklich äh in einem globalen Peer-Review unter Beteiligung aller nur irgendwie erdenklich kompetenten äh Menschen zustande gekommen ist.
Also AIS so mal als ein Beispiel eines bisher immer noch als sicher geltenden Verschlüsselungsstandards, der
sehr viel unsichere, nachweislich unsichere ältere Sachen wie das ersetzt hat,
Das sind eigentlich eher die Erfolgsgeschichten einer solchen internationalen Kooperation, gerade im kryptographischen Bereich. Ja, also dieses immer dieses deutsche Forschung bla, das ist einfach, weiß nicht, da irgendwie fast gar nicht zu äußern.
Na und dann bin ich ein bisschen überrascht, äh also dass es kam dann relativ viele Presseanfragen in letzter Zeit zum Schengen-Netz, denn äh was wir in der Sendung hier auch schon behandelt hatten
den Vorschlag damals noch von Rene Obermann. Jetzt ist es inzwischen ein Vorschlag von Kanzlerin Merkel. Ähm,
Schengen Netz, Schengenrouting muss jetzt sein, ne, also innereuropäisches äh Internet machen
haben wir hier alles schon behandelt, deswegen glaube ich, braucht man da nicht, also will ich jetzt nicht im Detail nochmal zu auf,
ich man merkt, ich bin eh nicht mehr in der Lage, mich vernünftig zu oder mich mich äh besonnen zu den Themen zu äußern.
Ja, ich muss muss ja noch daum und retten auf den letzten Metern.
Ja, wir schneiden gleich ein bisschen wat.
Das machen wir doch nie,
Zweiter Meldungsteil, wo ich äh nichts beizutragen habe, weil ich das überhaupt nicht mitbekommen habe.
Wir erinnern uns an das Leistungsschutzrecht. Du hast es ja noch bezeichnet als dieses peinliche Etwas, was dann hoffentlich bald verschwinden wird
ein Jahr danach, äh kommen äh kommen jetzt der Axel Springer und der Burda Verlag neben sich noch zehn weitere Verlage mit in ihre Koalition und beauftragen die VG Media,
Google und Co herauszufordern. Und zwar haben sie es erstmal sie wollen das Leistungsschutzrecht,
mit Hilfe der VG Media gegenüber Dougla durchsetzen,
Matthias Döpfner, bekannt ähm sagte, wir haben jetzt die große Chance, selbst über die gewerbliche Verwertung von journalistischen Inhalten zu entscheiden und da möchten sie jetzt quasi die VG Media als äh die Instanz nehmen, die dann da die Interessen der,
Verlage auch ähm vertritt,
Und zwar werden sie fünfzig Prozent an dieser Vereinigung einfach übernehmen und dort einen Tarif für die Onlinenutzung durch Dritte definieren.
Fertig. So, dann gibt's einen gibt's einen Tarif, der wird dann von der VG Mediaform äh äh.
Dann schicken die eine E-Mail an Google und dann schicken die Checks.
So ungefähr stellen sie sich das vor.
Mhm. Okay. Na, viel Spaß. Das wird bestimmt total toll.
Ne, und dann wird auch wieder natürlich ihnen gesagt, ja, Freunde,
Ist euch klar, dass euer ganzer Mist einfach darin äh gipfeln kann, dass ihr einfach aus dem Google Index rausfliegt, weil Google nicht für eure Snippets Geld bezahlen wird? Und äh,
da sagt, gehen sie dann einfach davon aus, dass sie nicht davon ausgehen, dass sie entfernt würden,
Jetzt ist die Frage, ob sie das meinen, weil sie sich sicher sind, naja, ja.
Interessant ist, dass diese VG Media, die gibt's ja noch gar nicht so lange. Ähm, wenn ich das richtig sehe, hat die sich zwanzig zehn überhaupt erst gegründet.
Verwertungsgesellschaft für die Urheber und Leistungsschutzrechte der privaten Fernseh- und Hörfunksender.
Definition gerade her.
Ihrer Webseite.
Ach so, hier gibt's eine Wikipedia, da steht noch eine andere. Interessant, da heißt es, Gesellschaft zur Verwertung der Urheber- und Leistungsschutzrechte von Medienunternehmen. Ich halte eine GmbH, ne. Also eine,
Lobbyform. Naja gut, ich meine, da gibt's jetzt nicht viel zu berichten. Äh wir.
Es es wird es wird halt schon ein sehr Krieg, hier wird spannend, weil sie ja sagen, okay, wir gehen nicht davon aus, dass wir aus dem Google Index entfernt werden, weil ähm Google hat ja eine Markt beherrschende Stellung und deswegen dürfen die uns gar nicht rauswerfen.
Aha. Sie sind verpflichtet, einem Geld zu bezahlen sozusagen.
Genau. Das war immer das Ziel bei diesen Leistungsschutzrecht. Und ähm.
Ja ja, das äh und ähm halte ich wirklich für sehr interessantes Argument.
Mir aber ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen, dass sie damit durchkommen, aber ich bin gespannt, äh wie, wie, wie weit sich unser Rechtssystem an der Stelle noch dehnen lässt.
Ich bin auch gespannt, aber.
Und Risse.
Also ich in so die letzten Monate lassen mich ja etwas des illusioniert zurück.
Gut. Haben wir noch was? Nö? Dann war's das.
Noch ein bisschen schneiden jetzt.
Dann war's das. Ja, fein. Dann können wir jetzt auch einfach.
Könnten einfach Schluss machen.
Tschüss sagen, oder? Wollen wir das machen?
Ja, ja, geht hin und empöret euch. So.
Dann gewinnt auch hier ein Integrationsbambi. Bis bald.